Ali is in Minneapolis hi Ali how are you
I'm doing well how are you better than I
deserve what's up okay well I recently
joined the SPU and I'm in my third week
just looking for my accountability
partner and I would just I would like
some guidance about how to proceed okay
so I have poor credit I'm about fifty
six thousand dollars and that I want to
pay off that I want to save money I want
to leave a legacy to my son but more
importantly I want to teach him how to
handle money I've realized that you know
the 1395 per month I'm paying with the
rent is not smart so I'd like to
purchase a home and I've managed to stay
out of collections so thank God that's
not what my credit is so poor I don't
have anything safe for college from my
son I'm recently divorced I've had very
recently a series of unexpected
financial problems and I cannot sell my
car so um what do you suggest well
you're obviously in your first week of
the class in the in the materials for
the class was the complete guide to
money in the book in that book is the
baby steps that we talked about in the
class and that we talked about here and
that's your best process through this
and so let's walk through what that
looks like of course starting to do a
written budget and being very organized
and making every dollar scream at the
top of its lungs because you're
finishing it so tight okay is a big deal
when you start doing a detailed budget
and you can do that at every dollar calm
on your iPhone or Android for free jump
on there it's our it's our online
budgeting tool and it's powerful it's a
great app okay and do it with your
desktop as well so doing your budget
will help you considerably and what is
your household income I me about seventy
five thousand dollars a year and what do
you owe on your car about twenty
thousand okay and what other debts do
you have you said you had fifty-six
thousand it's mostly credit cards I
purchased furniture with credit cards
and Target cards and other nonsense like
that I do have a twenty three thousand
dollar student loan okay all right
so that's 43 between a car and the
student loan yes and then the rest of it
the other 13 is credit cards yes okay
all right good and you make 70 that's
good news in your 39th hour 1395 rents
okay I don't recommend people buy a
house okay until they're debt-free okay
and have an emergency fund because the
house will not be a blessing okay it's a
bad long-term plan which is what you
were saying and I agree with you to rent
we don't want to be renting ten years
from now but I'm going to want you to
roll up your sleeves have you you and
your child have absolutely no life yes
for the next for the next two years okay
and and you're going to pay off thirty
thousand dollars a year out of your
seventy thousand which means you're on
beans and rice rice and beans and you're
going to be a hundred percent debt-free
two years from now okay
that's doable out of seventy I'm hopeful
no it is you can do that but you're not
going to have any life you're not gonna
see the inside of a restaurant less
you're working that that's fine what do
you suggest about the cards twenty
thousand I've tried to sell it out or I
just pay it off pay it off okay got it
it's not out of line unless you just
hate the car do you hate it I love it
okay I would just pay it off and keep it
our rule of thumb on cars is if you can
pay it off within pay off all your debts
within two years which you can and the
car is less than half your annual income
which it is then it's a capable car okay
and once we get this stuff paid off in
two years then you're going to finish
your emergency fund yep and then you're
going to say for your down payment on
your house and that's your order of
attack and so you're about three years
from buying your home not ten years not
30 years but not ten months okay and
that walks you into a very sane process
because buying a home when you have
absolutely no money and a bunch of dead
around your neck
I mean Murphy will move in is in your
spare bedroom bring us three cousins
broke desperate stupid with it
everything that can go wrong will like
all these little pop-up emergencies
you've had you'll have ten more of them
if you buy a house okay you're asking
for it in other words so don't ask for
just walk through those baby steps that
we outline very very clearly and get but
listen if you cut up all your credit
cards yet
working on it working on it didn't take
that long how many of you got I've got
about by 14 to 19 I've paid off three of
them and I don't use them at all but I'm
doing that dumb emergent well there
could be an emergency yeah well you need
to you need to get them out when you get
off the phone it'll take you about four
minutes to cut them up you got it I will
do that and just let's we're off of them
we're going to get on a plane we got a
thousand dollars in the bank
we're going to lean in we're going to
change your life
yeah old are you how old am I
thirty five and I had a sink and how
long have you been single a little less
than a year and I'm working through the
divorce now that's some extra part of
what you've gone through if you're in or
unless you're a psychopath if you're a
normal human is the pain and the
emotional distress of a divorce yes and
it it takes a little of your confidence
away it takes a little the edge off your
hope and it makes it hard to see a light
at the end of the tunnel that's not an
oncoming train yeah and so I just give
you permission to have been there but
we're not going to stay there
thank you okay so you're going to be
fine you're only 33 you said 35 30 37 so
37 oh you can't Noldor while we're
talking
but anyway so by the time you are 40
you're going to be debt-free with an
emergency fund and it probably saved up
your down payment for your home amen
that's a pretty cool place to be that's
worth that's what the math tells me now
and I kind of think talking to you
you're a person who's ready to step into
the Grace and the light of the future
and away from the pain and crap of the
past you're about ready to do it
I'm spin ready well so you stay in that
class and I'm here too if you've got any
questions you call me back as you go
along I'll walk with you kiddo you can
do this thank you sir I appreciate it
I'm proud of you this is the Dave Ramsey
show open phones a triple 8 8 2 5 5 2 2
5 you ever been there
where you get smacked my life so hard
that's your eyes crossing Casey Farley
for a little bit everything's a little
foggy and people that are have
standing around you you just want to hit
them ever been there where it's rough I
mean you're standing in sewage up to
your neck you know what I'm talking
about
you go into a divorce you went through
losing everything in a bankruptcy or you
have a child that's misbehaving or
somebody's ill in the family ever been
there
most people have proverbs says Hope
deferred makes the heart sick like a
hope hopeless this it's hard to work
through but you can because you know
what the rest that proverbs says when
desire comes Oh
when desire comes and that's right where
she is you hear it I can hear it in her
voice when desire comes it is The Tree
of Life it's real hope is a real thing
God wasn't getting with you when he said
that I've got a plan for you it's not to
bring you harm but to bring you hope and
your heavenly father is crazy about you
he's got a plan for you this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]